comme chaque année la même période à
samsung nous sort son galaxy note enfin
ses galaxy note depuis dernière
smartphone avec un stylet qui servira
aussi bien pour la prise de notes pour
le dessin que pour plein de choses il ya
plein d'usagé justement cette année je
voulais présenter je vous les airs
présenté il ya quelques jours galaxy
note
20h20 ultra de nouveaux modèles
vachement cool et aujourd'hui on va se
parler de celui la luttre alors vous
l'avez vu dans le titre de la vidéo vous
avez cliqué vous le savez vous êtes
affranchis vous savez qu'on parle des
samsung galaxy note 20 ultra le plus
haut de gamme ultra vous savez c'est une
nouvelle référence qui arrivait en 2020
dans la gamme de samsung avec son galaxy
s 20 ultra skinny tel modèle qui
arrivait en plus du modèle plus
notamment sur la gamme s je vous parle
vous allez voir je vous parlais ce que
je voudrais tout de suite par contre sur
la gamme note vous aviez le galaxy note
10 grecs s'ils ne disent plus là vous
n'avez pas de galaxy note 20 de plus
vous avez un samsung galaxy note 20
samsung galaxy ne devint ultra tout ça
pour vous dire vous avez deux modèles en
gros voilà voyez vous ai perdu mais on
est quand même arrivé à la conclusion
donc aujourd'hui on se parle de ce
modèle il vient être intéressant
notamment pour trois usages important le
tout premier usage avec la productivité
le deuxième usage ça va être le multi
média divertissement le troisième usage
fait le côté plus créatifs photo vidéo
je vais tous vous détailler je vais tout
vous expliquer vous dire pourquoi ce
modèle est intéressant et surtout est-ce
qu'il est fait pour vous il ya un truc
qui fait l'adn de ce produit mais qu'il
y aussi un peu lusage qui peut beaucoup
plaire comme pas trop plaire et bien
celle usage du espagne qui est à
l'intérieur
est ce que vous dites le moi dès
maintenant aux commentaires est ce que
vous utilisez un smartphone de la gamme
galaxy note de samsung à cause ou grâce
en tout cas os peine marqué le mois en
bas en commentaire et si vous avez déjà
acheté un smartphone de samsung de la
gamme galaxy note est que vous l'avez
pas acheté pour le s pen dites moi quels
sont les usages que vous en avez tout de
suite en bas en commentaire mais avant
d'aller plus loin je vous avais tout de
suite à venir vous abonner parce que je
vous parle effectivement de nouveautés
de smartphones de samsung de télé je
vous parle également de mon collector je
parle de samsung mais je vous parle de
plein d'autres marques mais je vous
parle surtout de vous de votre vie
numérique des bons usages donc vous
invite dès maintenant à vous
vous avez petit bouton rouge en bas si
les rouges si vous ne vous êtes toujours
pas abonnés pour venir cliquez dessus
actionner la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrive à 100 la chaîne
avant d'aller plus loin sur les
différentes fonctionnalités et je vais
vous parler de la base et la base c'est
le produit tel qu'il est là c'est la
prise en main c'est design c'est tout le
travail qu'a fait samsung derrière en
termes de solidité en termes de
robustesse et en terme de finition déjà
il ya un truc que j'aime bien cette
nouvelle couleur qu'on n'avait pas
avancé le mystique bronze mais surtout
c'est un smartphone qui sent vraiment la
solidité qui sont la robustesse et qui
sont le sérieux à peu amener il est très
grand il pèse un peu lourd il pèse ici
213 g c'est pas le smartphone le plus
léger que vous allez avoir chez samsung
on vient l'utiliser à demain en venir à
naviguer pour mieux faire tout ce que
vous voulez c'est un smartphone qui est
robuste grâce au verre corning gorilla
glass de dernière génération qui est
résistant aux chutes jusqu'à 2 mètres et
surtout qui va vraiment être améliorées
contre les rayures et puis le deuxième
point c'est que c'est un smartphone qui
est certifié ip 68 que vous pouvez
immergé jusqu'à un mètre et demi d'eau
pendant 30 minutes alors c'est pas le
but mais l'idée c'est que si jamais il
rencontre la pluie vous êtes tranquille
évitez l'eau chlorée évitez l'eau salée
mais pour tout le reste ça devrait aller
prévient la prise en main alors
effectivement c'est un très grand
smartphone symbole c'est et on sait
quand on va sur sa gamme samsung galaxy
note est ce un smartphone qui y est
aussi relativement cher en version 12
giga de ram 256 go de stockage il vous
coûtera 1309 l'euro et en version 12 il
ya drame toujours 512 ziga de stockage
1409 feront alors effectivement c'est
cher c'est un gros budget mais on est
dans l'ultra c'était à peu près la même
chose sur le samsung galaxy s 20 ultra
on à ce qui se fait de mieux aujourd'hui
dans cette gamme là et ça forcément et
bien ça ce n'était d'ailleurs puisqu'on
en parle c'est un smartphone qu'il faut
venir protéger ses biens que vous ayez
le dernier corning gorilla glass ça
c'est superbe c'est très bien vous est
aussi une certification ip68 mais malgré
tout est bien un moment s'ils tombent
sur des zones peu irrégulière sur des
cailloux lorsque vous voulez vous
risquez de l'endommager et ça malgré
tout il faut vraiment venir se prémunir
le protégeons donc on est dans la partie
sponsorisés avec un partenariat avec mon
partenaire rhino chine qui propose plein
de jolis produits les gens n'est pas là
dedans rhinochill à une grande gamme
pour tous vos produits smartphones et
compagnie et en plus il dira même de
changer le packaging de leur boîte
on passe sur du blanc ici les coques de
protection pour les samsung galaxy note
20 ne font pas encore sorti mais je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description pour tout savoir des qu'elle
sortira pour vous puissiez vous vous les
procurer très très facilement rien plus
de 20 une remise
grâce aux codes pour eux tout est en bas
tout est expliqué dans la description
vous invite à aller faire un petit tour
comme ça vous saurez que riad école pour
tous vous a effectivement ça sur une
coque pour le google pixels 4 ha dont on
va parler si quelques jours vous trouver
l'équivalent pour le samsung galaxy note
20h20 ultra vous avez également des
bumper pendant les protégez vous avez
des protections d'écran et puis alors ça
c'est tout autre chose mais si ça vous
intéresse et bien opus devait des coques
pour vos airpod ça c'est assez rigolo de
toutes les couleurs je vous invite à
aller faire un petit tour en bas vous
cliquez sur le lien vous découvrez vous
avez un code promo et surtout vous serez
les premiers à être adapté pour pouvoir
venir protéger votre samsung galaxy note
20 ou notre vin ultra et ça croyez moi
c'est vachement bien
ce qui est important à savoir en termes
de performance c'est qu'ici vous avez un
exynos 990 12 giga octets de ram
la techno drame ici c'est ce qu'on va
voir mieux c'est de la lpddr2 5 et vous
avez en stockage je voulais 10 soit 256
soit 512 et si on est sûr de lui et fès
3.0 pour ceux qui n'auraient pas eu fs
3.0 lecture écriture très rapide la
lpddr2 5 c'est pareil si une techno
drame qui fonctionne très bien et qui
est beaucoup plus rapide que la
pellinière 4x mais ici le seul petit
bémol va se situer au niveau de l'exil
990 alors l'exil 990 marche très bien
mais vous êtes une version américaine
qui va tourner sur le snapdragon 865 et
lui il est plus rapide que l'exil 1990
donc là dessus c'est vraiment une notion
de business parce que si c'est le
processeur de qualcomm
ici on est chez samsung il ya des
ententes en tout cas ici en europe
on n'a pas de sens dragon 865 et c'est
un peu dommage parce que du coup votre
smartphone sera un peu moins performant
ça se joue à pas grand-chose mais malgré
tout dans les classements sur les
benchmarks vous allez voir qu'à une
différence est que votre samsung galaxy
note 20 ultra ya se faire surclasser par
de smartphones pourront instinct dragon
865 avec une technologie drame identique
et avec une technologie de stockage
identique ça c'est un point important
pour tous les technophiles pour tous
ceux qui aiment chasser le peut
détails et qu'ils veulent ce qui se fait
de mieux si vous êtes technophiles vous
savez probablement déjà ça derrière
différents commentaires mais est-ce
qu'après pour le commun des mortels ça
va vraiment changer grand chose en
entrant c'est un dragon 865,1 exynos 990
un petit peu mais pas grand chose mais
si vous aimez chercher la petite bête et
si vous voulez mettre de l'argent pour
avoir ce qui se fait mieux surtout à
1300 ou 1400 euros
eh bien je puisse comprendre qu'on se
pose cette question là bas en très petit
aparté il faut savoir qu'ici vous avez
une mémoire qui est extensive vous
pouvez rajouter une carte micro sd
jusqu'à un terrain de stockage les déjà
avec 256 gigauri 512 jia je pense que
vous avez vraiment de quoi faire mais
une fois de plus pour aller sur les
usages un peu plus professionnel
productivité si vous voulez stocker
beaucoup de choses à l'intérieur et bien
vous pouvez le faire donc ça c'est et
puisqu'on est dans les chiffres mais si
un score surtout de 533 1177 qu'il y ait
classé en huitième position en dessous
du xiaomi me dise si vous avez au dessus
beaucoup de stan dragon 865 ça explique
pourquoi ce smartphone se classe pas en
tête mais malgré tout voyez il se classe
parmi les meilleurs on a donc ici de la
performance pour la partie productivité
mais la partie productivité avec ce
samsung galaxy note 20 ultra les noms
sont vraiment le rouge en ce moment eh
bien elle vient surtout de cet objet là
ça c'est le s pen alors le style et il a
changé de place je sais pas si vous avez
vu ma vidéo de présentation mais je vous
le disais effectivement à cause de la
taille du blog photos normalement vous
l'aviez justice jiangsu est bien il a
déménagé de l'autre côté ce qui n'est
pas très grave qui sera probablement
bien pour les gauchers d'ailleurs si
vous êtes gaucher dites moi ce que vous
en pensez on va en commentaire ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne très très bien
et surtout se respecte il vient apporter
des usages en plus et tous les ans vous
avez de nouveaux gestes qui apparaît de
nouvelles fonctionnalités de nouvelles
possibilités
donc on est sur une mise à jour de ce
qu'on avait avec les samsung galaxy note
10 de l'année dernière on n'est pas sur
une très grosse révolution mais une
nouvelle fonctionnalité qui arrive et
pour tous les usagers et les amoureux du
spn eh bien c'est une bonne chose le
premier point c'est une diminution de la
latence alors la latence si vous n'êtes
pas hyper coutumier tout ça et bien
c'est l'intervalle de temps entre moment
où vous allez poser votre stylet vous
allez commencer à écrire moment où les
choses vont apparaître alors abonde avec
42 millisecondes autant dire que sa déjà
très très petit et très difficile de se
rendre compte comme ça là on arrive sur
neuf millisecondes en terme de
sensations lorsque j'écris lorsque j'ai
dessiné lorsque je vais faire des
oeuvres d'art j'ai une sensation
naturelle très naturel est ce qu'elle me
paraît être moi plus naturel que ce que
j'avais avec le galaxy note 10
l'année dernière très honnêtement ça se
joue à pas grand chose pourquoi je vous
dis ça parce que je ne suis pas une
personne qui utilise le s pen au
quotidien donc ce n'est pas forcément
moi qui vais m'en rendre compte le plus
néanmoins samsung garantie effectivement
une latence réduite donc c'est un vrai
bénéfice pour tous les utilisateurs
vous retrouverez également plein de
nouveautés notamment la fonction autorun
avec nos très bel accent qui viendra
aligner votre écriture si vous écrivez à
son projet ça vient vous le maître droit
vous avez également une organisation par
dossier dans votre application note et
vous avez le samsung
note 5 qui vous permettra la bora d'un
stockage dans le cloud fait vous avez
par une communication entre vos
différents appareils entre votre
tablette samsung galaxy tab s est
pourquoi pas votre samsung galaxy note
20 ultra et votre pc de l'autre côté
comme ça vos notes vont être disponibles
vous allez pouvoir commencer à
griffonner des notes sur votre
smartphone lorsque vous êtes dans un
transport quelque part et que vous avez
une idée et ensuite travailler l'éditer
en allant plus loin notamment sur votre
pc vous avez évidemment de la
reconnaissance de texte dans plein de
langues différentes et une
fonctionnalité qui vachement bien aussi
cette année c'est que vous pouvez venir
enregistrer dans différents formats et
notamment en powerpoint à l'orias
powerpoint ya world
il ya évidemment du pdf vous avez
également sur notre ville travaille
uniquement sur notre ville ultra la
fonctionnalité punk to share pour venir
partager du contenu depuis votre
smartphone la possibilité de venir
synchroniser votre smartphone avec
windows il ya un partenariat avec
microsoft et ça c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressant c'est du mirroring de votre
smartphone directement sur votre pc
le decs et sans fil vous pouvez donc
utiliser votre smartphone comme un petit
pc et vous avez une synchro de vos notes
dans onenote et également dans outlook
bon ça ça arrivera à partir du mois de
novembre 2020 l'autre gros bénéfice
d'avoir un très très grand écran comme
ça et bien c'est de pouvoir venir faire
du multitâche ce qu'on a vu arriver à
par le passé ce sont les réactions des
mouvements que vous faites qui vous
permettent de piloter votre smartphone
grâce à votre style et bien il ya cinq
nouveaux airs actionne sept années qui
viennent compléter les actions déjà
existants donc ça c'était le premier
usage est le deuxième gros usages qu'on
me retrouver ici c'est l' usage
multimédia parce que vous avez un très
grand écran de 6,9 pouces et quand je
dis très grand écran c'est vraiment très
très grand écran on est quasiment sûr du
7 pouces est l'intérêt d'avoir un très
grand écran comme ça c'est que ça vous
dégage beaucoup de place pour venir
regard
du contenu multimédia et pour toute la
partie divertissement alors pour
regarder du contenu sur netflix my canal
disney + youtube et tout ce que vous
voulez vous avez un confort de
visionnage qui est vraiment là en plus
ici vous êtes sur un écran dynamique
amoled qui va venir lutter contre la
lumière bleue c'est un écran bord à bord
vous avez une résolution maximale en w
qhd plus sinon vous pouvez aller en full
hd plus mais en plus de ça vous avez un
taux de rafraîchissement qui peut aller
jusqu'à 120 hertz vous pouvez donc
choisir d'être soit sur du 60 hertz et
ne pas en douter soient remontés jusqu'à
120 air si l'application peut permettre
d'utiliser du sang royal
maintenant le bémol qu'on va avoir là
dessus c'est que il va falloir faire
votre choix vous ne pouvez pas avoir de
w qhd plus et un taux de
rafraîchissement 120 hertz si vous
voulez un taux de rafraîchissement 120
hertz vous devez avoir du full hd plus
au maximum et ça c'est truqué un peu nos
mac c'est une fête plus du chipotage
mais à 1300 euros je pense qu'on peut
donner droit de chipoter puisque si vous
regardez ce que propose au pot avec son
opus find x2 pro-pouvoir du wqs des et
vous pouvez avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
ce qui si samsung ne vous propose pas
une fois qu'on a omis ce détail on est
sur un des plus beaux écrans qu'on
puisse retrouver sur le marché donc si
vous voulez profiter d'une des
meilleures dalle est bien avec le
samsung galaxy note 20 ultra vous serez
servis vous aurez tout ce qu'il faut
pour vous avez une date qui est
compatible hd hier 10 plus bon on a ce
qui se fait de mieux
ça marche très bien et en terme
d'expérience de visionnage vous ne
serait absolument pas déçu qui dit
multimédia dit également expérience
audio alors ici vous avez des hauts
parleurs stéréo parleurs stéréo qui
marche très bien vous avez un son qui
éclaire vous avez de la puissance pour y
monter le son ça devient pas saturer ça
marche alors on reste sur un smartphone
donc on va pas non plus avoir le top du
top du top de la qualité comme si vous
êtes d'une croissance est poussive ont
rallié sans votre télé chez vous mais
malgré tout ça fait vraiment bien le job
alors le seul petit bémol que je vais me
retrouver là dessus et bien c'est que
vous n'avez pas de haut parleurs en
façade avec la même directivité
programme vraiment une sensation
d'immersion complète vous avez un haut
parleur qui va se situer ici sur le côté
et qui marchera bien mais qui va venir
plus libéré du son dans cette partie là
tandis que vous avez un petit deuxième
haut parleurs qui est planqué ici et
qu'il a plus à voir cette activité par
l'at il ya un très très très léger
déséquilibre ce qui aurait été parfait
savoir un équilibre comme on peut
retrouver sur le xiaomi me dise promet
une fois de plus on est dans du
chipotage et croyez-moi quand talent
d'expérience de
zonage on a une source stéréo ça marche
bien c'est qualitatif et une fois de
plus vous en aurez pour votre argent
ici c'est pas nouveau on croit pas deux
prises jack par contre vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 qui vous permettront de
connecter très facilement vos besoins
vos écouteurs tout ce que vous voulez
pour avoir une expérience complètement
maximiser un autre point extrêmement
important pour la partie divertissement
multimédia c'est toute la partie gaming
comme vous avez de la performance ce que
je vous ai décrit un peu avant dans la
vidéo et bien vous fait tourner tous les
jeux de dupes les stores sens absolument
aucun problème
et en plus vous à cette année un
partenariat qui va encore plus loin avec
microsoft puisque vous retrouver ici
xbox game passe alors il nous faudra
avoir un abonnement et vous allez avoir
plus de 100 jeux directement sur votre
smartphone en cloud gaming
les jeux seront pas stockées dans votre
smartphone mais vous viendrez vous
connecter soit en wifi soit en 4g voire
5 g parce que oui effectivement ici vous
avez de la 5g alors il faut que
l'assemblée sont disponibles dans
d'autres pays que ceux disponibles
là vous vous situez il faut que vous
ayez souscrit un abonnement 5 g en wifi
à la maison ça ira très vite avec du
wifi 6 je peux pas vous donner
aujourd'hui mon retour par rapport à
l'expérience du game pad xbox parce que
le service n'est pas disponible et en
plus il vous faut pour certains jeux une
petite manette qu'il faut acheter en
plus mais ça viendra maximiser
l'expérience de gaming mais par contre
pour jouer à tous les jeux de dupes les
stars vous avez un smartphone qui est
puissant qui est performant avec une
qualité d'affichage qui est vraiment
irréprochable pour que ce soit pour le
10 min que ce soit pour du visionnage
série fine pour du travail pour les
réseaux sociaux pour tout ce que vous
voulez on a vraiment un smartphone qui
est au top et le troisième et dernier
grand usage c'est la partie photo vidéo
alors autant la gamme s et samsung c'est
vraiment la gamme photo ici dans la game
note on n'est plus dans la productivité
mais on retrouve néanmoins sur ce modèle
ultra et bien qu'on peut faire de mieux
voir quasiment de mieux avec pas moins
de quatre capteurs à l'arrière on
retrouve toutes ont eu très grand-angle
de 12 mégapixels tour f 2.2 en dessous
ou au milieu on va voir un grand temps
de 100 8 mégapixels couvre f 1.8 ip tout
en bas vous avez un téléobjectif 12
mégapixels qui ouvrait 3.0 avec un zoom
optique x 5 est un space zoom x 50 et
vous avez ici une petite caméra tough
qui est là pour le mode portrait qui est
là pour apporter de la profondeur de
champ tandis qu'à l'avant plan kelly si
vous avez une toute petite caméra de 10
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 bien qu'on
soit dans la gamme ultra samsung a fait
le choix de ne pas vous mettre de spies
um
x 100 comme vous l'avez sur le samsung
galaxy s 20 ultra pour venir différencie
les gammes alors bien évidemment vous
venez différencier de par le stylet mais
il faut quand même que le samsung galaxy
s ii ultra est aussi une différence est
un bénéfice sans quoi il se vendrait
plus il y aurait pas d'intérêt lâché
sous pli coûtent quasiment le même prix
donc ici vous avez un super zoom jusqu'à
fois cinq ans pour regarder le résultat
dans quelques instants tandis que sur le
samsung galaxy s 20 ultra vos annonces
pezous jusqu'à fois sans voilà le
résultat photo est intéressant à
regarder
alors je vous le dis tout de suite c'est
une mise à jour qui devait arriver et
qui m'aurait permis d'avoir les
dernières améliorations au niveau des
caméras pour vraiment pouvoir voir ce
que ça donne et mais la mise à jour à
l'heure à laquelle je tourne toujours
pas arrivé mais il faut savoir qu'il va
y avoir des améliorations du rendu au
niveau de votre caméra et je vais vous
montrer quels sont les petits points que
j'ai pu relever qu'il fonctionne pas
alors là pour la retrouver sur le
capteur principal emploi gens vous le
voyez les conditions sont idéales ça
fonctionne très très bien l'ultra grand
angle et bien on vient ensuite se
rapprocher en x 2 ça fonctionne
et là des conneries man x 4 voyez je
pense que c'est là qu'est une petite
correction logicielle à voir et vous le
voyez ici notamment au niveau des arbres
parce que là je pense qu'on est sur le
capteur principal qui vient travailler
jusque là et après on est sur le zoom
périscopique puisque regarder si je vais
me rapprocher vous voyez la différence
la chaussée toutes les caméras principal
la tournelle périscopique qui bossent
ensemble et c'est là où ça vous fait un
peu un peu le bazar avec un côté qui est
pas net à côté qui est très nette
et ça soit si toutes les choses qui vont
être corrigés d'un point de vue logiciel
mais sinon dans l'ensemble
mise à part ces petits points de détails
qu'on peut retrouver entre voyez ces
personnes là il ce monsieur qui est la
mise à part ça le résultat est quand
même relativement très correct mais
fonctionne bien on se rapproche ensuite
en x 10 et bien on voit bien l'écriteau
glace on voit bien les personnages ça
fonctionne
dès qu'on se rapproche enfin c'est un
peu moins bon et forcément on est tout
de suite un peu plus lisse et vous aussi
vous sortir des images de qualité
alors peut-être qu'il y aura une
amélioration aussi au niveau de la
caméra là dessus ça s'est une fois de
plus de choses que je peux pas vous dire
à l'heure actuelle
et dès qu'on arrive au x 50 brossard de
toute façon deux fois 50 on est au bout
du bout du bout ce pour vous montrer la
techno c'est pas terrible mais si vous
voulez vraiment venir zoomer davantage
avec un smartphone de chez samsung il
faut aller sur le galaxy s 20 ultra et
besoin quelque chose qui marche très
très bien d'ailleurs je vous renvoie mon
test pour tout savoir caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle dans les deux cas
c'est très cool et ça marche très très
bien on continue ici avec le zoom x 2 ça
marche très bien
x 4 x 10 c'est très bon foie vince a
fait le taf simplement extraordinaire
mais ça fait le taf est bon il faut 50
on oublie caméra principale l'ultra
grand angle x 2 x 4 voyons les sur une
scène qui est un peu moins complexe
donc ça marche x 10 de la même manière
c'est très bon on continue avec le x 20
qui fera très bientôt à bombay x 50
assez normal tout c'est un petit peu
moins bon là on est sur le bonne
nourriture et vollmond mourinho je
trouve assez efficace et notamment ici
ça donne extrêmement fins dans la photo
de lui c'est quand même plutôt de pas
mal aussi est là on est sur la caméra
principale là on a peut-être quelques
petits points qui vont être améliorés
par la mise à jour logicielle un petit
flou qui est ici là c'est pas fou donc
voilà c'est toutes les petites choses
qui je pense vont être corrigés on passe
ensuite sur l' ultra grand-angle le
rendu global est quand même beaucoup
moins qualitatif on se rapproche en x 4
on peut mais c'est pas dingue mais vous
voyez si vous voulez vraiment pouvait le
faire et jusqu en faut dix mail à mon
avis on oublie vraiment caméra
principale l'ultra grand angle c'est pas
génial le x 4 et le x 10 la voyez c'est
vraiment très très bon on est la nuit on
s'est vraiment il faut te nuit caméra
principale l'ultra grand temps que c'est
moins précis moins terrible on se
rapproche en x 4 ça vient lycée c'est
quand même beaucoup moins bien et on
continue ici ensuite en x 10 caméras
principal c'est vraiment bien la gestion
des lumières entre les arbres qui sont
éclairés le ciel toutes les parties de
londres est vraiment bien géré on passe
en ultra grand temps que c'est un peu
moins bon on se rapproche ces mois
terribles x 10 on oublie caméra
principale ultra-grand-angle fois quatre
fois nice caméra principale ça
fonctionne et également ici le mode
portrait est vraiment très très bon
grâce à la caméra tough s'est
extrêmement bien des tours et deux
partout même au niveau des cheveux ici
et même sur l'ultra grand temps que
c'est très cool alors ici j'étais sous
un arbre et une branche qui passe juste
là et c'est très drôle parce que voyez
on voit bien tout l'ombre ici ça l'a
bien connu les feuilles grâce au laser
ici n'est pas contre la petite branche
eh bien il n'a pas eu mais bon ça c'est
une tonne qui est très complexe et
dupont détails mais le détourage au
niveau des doigts dément
de la tête de ce que vous voulez marche
très très bien donc pour moi le résultat
est vraiment la hauteur et obtenu sur la
caméra de celle fille qui est très très
très bonne naturel je trouve ça vraiment
bien et même en ultra grand-angle sur la
caméra de celle ci ça fera parfaitement
bien le taf donc de façon un peu globale
pour moi il ya un très très bon boulot
qui est fait au niveau de la photo on
attend ces mises à jour qui vont venir
corriger ces petites erreurs
ces petites imperfections mais dans
l'ensemble le résultat est vraiment à la
hauteur le mode single take construction
très très bien ce que c'est facile
pourrait monter jusqu'à 15 secondes
il fait plus le rendez-vous est plutôt
cool ça vous sort sur une seule et même
grande vidéo soit à partir d'une vidéo
15 secondes vous avez des petites vidéos
pour ça c'est la vidéo complète ce poids
vidéo un peu rapide qu'il faut entité
fameux sympa des photos du noir et blanc
du portrait des effets enfin vous avez
pas mal de résultats différents
et ça une fois de plus je dois
reconnaître que ces femmes très très
efficace autre nouveauté qui est
vraiment intéressante et notamment pour
la prise de son est ce que vous
choisissiez de soi insomnies
directionnelle un saut de l'avant un son
de l'ariège ou alors carrément en usb
bluetooth et si j'en ai pas de connecter
les pouilles très très bien prendre vos
grec sibbles live et ça marche très très
bien et vous pouvez même réglé en plus
votre bien passé loin 12 db jusqu'à + 12
db beaupréau faites comme vous voulez ça
l'est pour une faute plus de votes
ressources et de la distance
le fait par exemple de mettre un homme
dit directionnelle je vais capter le son
d'un peu partout donc si vous êtes ado
discuter d'un côté et lot de la camair
ça ira bien mais le problème c'est pas
moi c'est lui tout seul de ce côté-là
agrégé récupère ainsi le bouhris pièces
qui viennent notre côté puisque le micro
alors pour regarder contrôle cherrière
je me mets de côté le son est bon aussi
maintenant je passe en son avant montant
d un peu mais sans vraiment optimisé si
je me positionne de l'autre côté il a
joué mais de l'autre côté tout de suite
c'est beaucoup mieux tandis qu'ici j'ai
choisi le sens arrière uniquement le
micro de ce côté là elle va fonctionner
ce qui fait que je n'aurai pas le son de
pièces de l'autre côté mais si par
contre je me déplace eh bien une fois de
plus c'est pas vraiment son loyer mais
là il ya moins de son excédent mal ça
c'est de la vidéo 8 k alors ici par
contre l'as cannes elle n'est pas là ça
bouge c'est un peu l'inconvénient mais
bon on voit si vous voulez finement week
est en tout cas vous pouvez le faire
si par contre vous et de la super
stabilisation bien vous passez en 1080p
à 30 images par seconde mais par contre
là ça ne bouge
absolument pas et autre poids qui est
vachement bien c'est le speed vous voyez
ce faire des zooms tout doux ça me
paraît vraiment de venir travailler sur
ma production ce que je veux dire filmer
directement au royaume
je me rapproche extrêmement doucement
plus vite si je souhaite mais je fais
vraiment comme je veux et je trouve que
une fois de plus ça s'est vraiment bien
pensé ce smartphone à une batterie de
4500 milliampères heures vous avez la
recharge rapide
5 watts de la recharge sans fil 15 watts
également de l'argent versé l'autonomie
c'est toujours un peu complexe parce que
tout va dépendre de vous de votre
configuration de vos usages de ce que
vous allez en faire
si vous êtes en wqs des en permanence à
regarder des films et bien évidemment
vous en douterez la batterie ne va pas
durer très très longtemps si vous êtes
parent est tout le temps en usage sur du
120 air de la même manière ça va pas
venir durée extrêmement longtemps mais à
côté de ça vous avez une technique
intéressante qui va à venir switcher
automatiquement et intelligemment entre
du 100 m et du 60 hertz pour éviter de
consommer davantage
mais sur les âges un peu standard c'est
un smartphone que vous gardez une
journée une journée et demie son
problème et si vous voulez vraiment
mollo mollo deux jours 20 ça dépend une
fois de plus de vous de vos usages de ce
que vous allez en faire une d'ailleurs
dit man commentaires à vous quels sont
vos usages et est-ce que vous pensez que
ce smartphone duré longtemps si vous
l'utilisez côté logiciel on tombe sur un
nuage 2.5 basé sur un android disent bon
ben je sais pas si vous connaissez
mais ça fonctionne bien c'est pratique
vous avez plein de possibilités plein de
réglages vous avez un mode sont vous
avez un mode clair vous venez vraiment
faire plein plein plein de choses pour
moi il ya deux typologies de personnes
qui vont venir gâcher ce smartphone dell
la toute première c'est les personnes
qui aiment vraiment le style et qui
travaille avec un stylet au quotidien ou
qui ont vraiment un usage ce qui
représente à mon avis pas énormément de
monde sauf les personnes qui sont déjà
clients de la gamme note et qui aiment
la gamme noté qui veulent renouveler
leur smartphone de la gamme note alors
si vous avez acheté
samsung galaxy note 10 ne disent plus
les nerfs
je suis pas sûr que ce soit extrêmement
intéressant aujourd'hui d'aller changer
pour celui là vous avez un smartphone
création qui marche très bien
si vous avez un smartphone des années
antérieures peut-être pourquoi pas à
voir si vous avez vraiment de nouveaux
usages avec les nouveaux ericsson et
compagnie bons à voir la deuxième
typologie de personnes sont toutes les
personnes qui n'ont pas besoin de stylet
mais qui part qu'on vole très grand
écran qui va les smartphones performants
qu'ils veulent de la qualité pour le
visionnage et notamment le multimédia et
qui veulent également un très bon
appareil photo alors on pourrait se dire
on peut aller sur le samsung galaxy s
valtra c'est vrai mais là vous avez un
écran vie quand même un peu plus grand
vous avez un smartphone qui aura les
mêmes techno en termes de performances
et qui sera aussi très actuel voilà
vraiment ces deux typologies de
personnes que je viens vraiment voir
d'ailleurs dit moi vous si vous vous
reconnaissez dans un de ces deux
catégories
et si vous pourriez en tout cas vous été
tenté ou si vous vous êtes déjà laisser
tenter à nouveau samsung galaxy note 20
ultra voilà pour ce que j'avais à vous
dire sur ce nouveau smartphone moi je
trouve
vraiment bien très réussi très très beau
boulot de la part de samsung une fois de
plus des écrans maîtrisée et une fois de
plus dans vraiment l'idée de la
productivité de la création de la photo
également avec notamment le s pen et
c'est très très belle configuration à
vous de me dire vous maintenant comment
vous le trouvez en bas en commentaire
est ce que vous pourriez vous été tenté
ce que vous êtes déjà laissé tenter et
s'il vous intéresse et que vous n'êtes
toujours pas éventer vous aimez les
liens en bas par la description sur ce
jeu rendez vous extrêmement rapidement
partout la plainte de l'indien attaque
ne s'arrête pas à porter vous viendra
beaucoup d'amour et après
kalt à dia
[Musique]